and he is with us in Dallas Texas hey
Andy how are you fine Dave I've got
financial peach that's good news sir
well thanks for participating in our
millionaires email what is your net
worth sir 2.5 million and I can kind of
share I've heard the questions I can
learn through real quick could you just
let me take a minute sure
I'm 58 years old let's say work fifty
eight years old I don't want to Rick my
marriage over the air okay we're 58
years old been married 29 years the 2.5
million net worth is 1.7 in retirement
400 K in investments in cash and 400 in
a home we have no debt we've been in
baby step seven for nine years we've had
no inheritance when we got married in
1986 we were broke I love when you
talked about the stats that you give in
the classes you you end it with well if
I'm half wrong you know so and so well I
can tell you you're not half wrong I'm
more than half on this this net worth
ought to be tripled this how to just
follow the baby steps from day one our
household income average for the last
since we've been married in eighty eight
thousand presently he had 160 thousand
I'm a manager at a small manufacturing
facility my wife is a part-time ESL
English as a second language teacher we
did it all with biblical principles of
giving saving spending is all about
behavior our keys were just working
together getting out of debt we haven't
had a car loan or a credit card debt in
25 years I did some stupid you know
buying new cars I made some really
stupid decisions and I always think
about this if you got a PhD in D UMB I'm
at least a master's okay but we did even
through all this time making somewhat
not such great decisions we stuck to a
budget with safe retirement if you go
back in time I became a Christian in
1985 and married my wife in 86 let me
tell you I married up big-time over my
head I brought to the merits $10,000 a
debt car loan credit cards she was
raised on a farm she was used to paying
cash for everything she won me over
simply with her gentle and quiet spirit
now the first Peter story principle
look together we started budgeting
communicating working together and in no
time we paid off a personal debt but we
still have a mortgage five years later
our son was born which was an emotional
time because we had four miscarriages
along the waist you got to know this boy
that's with us and when I read God's
Word about he gave us only sent about
hits me right in a heart at that time my
wife decided to stay home with him so
this was 1991 our network at this time
is still less than $100,000 this is 24
years ago well we kept budgeting we kept
saving to kept investing not as
intensive some of your really gazelle
intense colic which I loved listening to
we made dumb decisions Dave I bought new
cars you know I paid cash I bought
bought new cars I'm not a good decision
I bought rental real estate in another
state at a bad price about individual
stocks that went to zero what I'm saying
is in spite of these less than optimum
decisions we've still putting money into
account we're still saving we still stay
away from debt then in 2004 the
intensity started in 2006 when we paid
off our mortgage my goodness that's when
the world started to accelerate baby
step seven it was amazing I looked up in
2011 five years later my net worth was
1.7 million I've already read the total
buddy makes four okay and you don't know
wife and I decided to do it at one point
seven million or network without what we
could do now we went to an FPU class now
I got to tell you in addition to the
biblical practical effective method you
teach the entertainment value seen you
run around on stage was worth the price
alone okay
it was fantastic so we are absolutely on
fire so the stats from last year just to
give you know our household income was
160,000 I paid about 40,000 in taxes
which leaves 120 we gave about 35,000 to
the church and other ministries we saved
about 35,000 so when you put those
together roughly 70,000 that leaves us
50 now we did have a kind of a tough
year medically nothing serious we had a
couple of surgeries and 7000 came up
over that left 43,000 let me tell you
43,000 is a
pile of money when you don't have debt
and you know any taxes are paid we had a
great time we traveled some we enjoyed
life we had no financial stress it was
absolutely amazing
and so we are absolutely on fire now
with with the principles you treat each
and the only thing you've done wrong you
didn't teach him to me 30 years ago no
so what part did giving play in the
holes of the whole process over the last
30 years it was big I mean it's like you
said generosity just it's just a trick I
tell you that the biggest things are
integrity and generosity and just
following biblical principles it just
opens your heart and you know you don't
expect to get one for one when you go
but God just blesses us with just wisdom
mm-hmm did you what do you do for a
living I'm a manager at a small
manufacturing facility my wife is a
part-time ESL teacher did you graduate
from college yes I did was a degree in
what in chemical engineering what was
your GPA it was about us it was pretty
good 3.6 I think that's pretty good yeah
good for you excellent all right very
good
that's fun that's fun so what do you
tell me what do you tell young people
now when you run into these 32 year olds
and they really wonder if they can land
where you're landing if they can be 58
with a paid-for house on two and a half
million dollar net worth well it's
interesting you asked that question
because remember I got a son and he's
married to there's a beautiful girl and
I take what we're most proud of dave is
not that we built a network it's not
that we've given thousands to the church
it's not that we paid off our home
mortgage it's the fact that those two
has embraced these principles they're
they're on fire he's working at
chick-fil-a in Atlanta downtown
headquarters he graduated with a
business degree an MBA degree with no
debt and we didn't pay a dime Wow took
the ATP seven times until he hit that
threshold scholarship it's great GPAs a
lot better than - the 3.90 worked
through college he did not scholarships
now she's going through occupational
therapy school there cash flowing it
it's amazing
she's working full-time going to school
on the weekends and their cash flow and
occupational therapist
so this is what I tell people I know it
can be done because I see living proof
of it right here these are 23 to 24 year
old right here I'm talking about mm-hmm
very we are so pumped what we're doing
FPU we're going to bring legacy journey
to the church smart money smart kids to
our church Thank You Saul and Rockwall
Texas we just love it we just just keep
on preaching the day if you know such a
good sermon every time I listen to your
podcast like going to church every week
I needed you thank you Andy that's
amazing
you